évidemment et sans surprise le
Gouvernement est défavorable à
l'adoption de la motion référendaire qui
a été proposée j'ai entendu finalement
trois arguments ou trois questions
auxquelles je souhaite apporter les
positions du gouvernement en réponse
première argument concerne la question
de la recevabilité nous avons évoqué ce
sujet hier est-ce que cette réforme doit
être portée dans le cadre d'un projet de
loi de financement la sécurité sociale
rectificative nous avons eu l'occasion
hier madame la rapporteur général
moi-même d'apporter un centre d'éléments
de réponse et de rappeler que le cadre
dans lequel nous sommes les conséquences
de cette réforme sur les comptes sociaux
pour l'année 2023 rend à la fois
légitime recevable et donc justifier le
recours à un projet loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale il y a malgré
tout et c'est une parenthèse que je fais
quelque chose d'assez cocasse pardon
pour cette expression à entendre
reprocher au gouvernement d'avoir
organisé une forme d'obstruction pour
deux raisons la première c'est que le
temps de débat dont dispose le Parlement
sur cette réforme est supérieure au
temps de débats dont à disposer
probablement sur les deux réformes
précédentes et les choix fait par le
Sénat d'ouvrir un nombre de jours
supplémentaires par rapport à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a illustré ou
conforter celui-ci puis il y a une
deuxième raison c'est que à ma
connaissance ce n'est pas le
gouvernement qui est devant l'Assemblée
nationale a déposé plus de 20000
amendements dans des séries
identiques je peux vous assurer que
j'avais plus hâte d'entrer dans les
sujets de fonds que d'examiner ces
amendements identiques la deuxième
question à laquelle je vais apporter la
position du gouvernement concerne
finalement la légitimité ou l'intérêt
qu'il y a à maintenir au Parlement cette
capacité à apporter examiner la réforme
des retraites et à travailler sur ces
questions là je crois très fortement à
cette légitime légitimité de la
démocratie représentative et du
Parlement pour débattre des retraites
j'y crois parce que l'histoire récente
nous a montré que toutes les réformes de
retraite depuis 1980 ont été examinés
par le Parlement il n'y a qu'un
faire la différence cela a été évoqué
par certains orateurs puisque en 1980 la
réforme a été mise par voie d'ordonnant
mise en oeuvre par voie d'ordonnance
après que le Parlement est habilité le
gouvernement à le faire mais le
Parlement c'est toujours saisi de cette
question des retraites et a pu
accompagner mettre en œuvre des progrès
qui sont des progrès très substantiels
pour l'ensemble des assurés je ne prends
qu'un exemple qui a été évoqué notamment
par le Président c'est la question des
carrières longues lorsque l'on se
retourne sur un passé récent à 20 ans
avant 2003 l'âge de départ à la retraite
était de 60 ans la durée de cotisation
requise était de 37 ans et demi et dans
un système tel que on le connaissait un
assurer une assuré qui travaille qui
faisait des études une licence une
maîtrise qui entrait sur le marché du
travail à 22 ans et demi travailler très
exactement 37 ans et demi et bénéficier
d'une retraite à taux plein 60 ans et
dans le même temps
ses camarades de classe à l'école
pouvait commencer à travailler très tôt
à 14 ans à 15 ans à 16 ans et devait
aller jusqu'à 60 ans et ainsi cotiser 44
45 46 ans pour bénéficier d'une retraite
à taux plein c'est la création du
dispositif de carrière longue dans la
réforme de 2003 qui a apporté une
première réponse et depuis chaque
réforme examiner débattu adopté par le
Parlement a permis de diminuer cet écart
de durée de cotisation à l'échelle d'une
vie pour faire en sorte qu'aujourd'hui
nous arrivions à une situation et ça
sera encore plus vrai si cette réforme
est adoptée où l'écart de durée de
cotisation requise sera finalement
ramené à moins d'un an parfois à
quelques trimestres parce qu'on sait
qu'il n'y a pas de perfection à la
matière et ce seul exemple montre qu'il
y a un intérêt à ce qu'elle Parlement
puisse se saisir ces sujets les creuser
les amender les approfondir et apporter
des dispositions techniques qu'un examen
par voie référendaire ne permettrait pas
enfin la troisième question à laquelle
je veux apporter une réponse c'est
justement quel serait l'intérêt quelle
serait
plutôt de la démarche de confier cette
question ce débat et cette réforme à une
question référendaire je crois et cela
était dit par plusieurs intervenants que
la complexité du sujet je l'ai évoqué
hier en réponse à la discussion générale
interdit cette démarche interdit cette
démarche parce que aucune réponse
binaire ne peut constituer une réponse à
la question des retraites il a été
évoqué par plusieurs intervenants et
avec des ondes très différents la
question des femmes et en particulier la
question des maires puisque ont été
évoquées les questions relatives au
trimestre accordée et validé à
l'occasion d'une maternité ou au-delà
des trimestres raccordés pour
l'éducation des enfants je suis
convaincu mais ça peut faire l'objet
d'un débat je suis absolument convaincu
que pas un couple
aucun parent aucune femme ne décide
d'avoir un enfant pour espérer avoir en
contrepartie telle ou telle trimestre ou
telle ou telle majoration c'est un
projet de vie c'est un projet personnel
c'est une construction par contre je
suis absolument convaincu que la
maternité tout comme le fait d'élever
des enfants peut-être soit un frein voir
un empêchement à cotisé soit un frein à
la progression à la promotion
professionnelle et donc un facteur
d'inégalité professionnelle notre
système de retraite ne compte rien
aucune disposition qui soit de nature à
marquer créer une inégalité entre les
femmes et les hommes ils traduit il
retranscrit dans le calcul des pensions
non pas une volonté d'inégalité mais
l'accumulation d'inégalité tout au long
de la vie et c'est évidemment la
question de l'égalité professionnelle
qui apportera la seule et vraie réponse
soutenable à la question de l'égalité
des pensions entre les femmes et les
hommes par contre notre système ne doit
pas s'empêcher de réparer et c'est pour
ça que j'ai dit hier combien nous
regardons avec bienveillance
l'amendement proposé par le président
Retailleau et adopté par la Commission
des affaires social pourquoi parce que
d'une part il permettra il permet de
maintenir un système un système qui
autorise une femme je parle uniquement
des trimestres liés à la maternité les
quatre dans le régime général les deux
dans le secteur public et cela renvoie
au débat sur les droits familiaux que
j'ai évoqué permettra à des femmes ayant
des caries
compléter leur carrière évitez la décote
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui et
c'est pour ça que c'est trimestre ont
été pensées dans un premier temps qu'on
met des contreparties et des trimestres
qui ne pouvaient être cotisées au moment
de la grossesse et de l'accouchement et
dans un deuxième temps comme un une
réponse peut-être aux carrière h mais
nous avons une situation qui fait
qu'avec l'augmentation pas celle-ci mais
l'augmentation depuis
1993 depuis 2003 pardonnez-moi de l'âge
de départ à la retraite nous avons une
situation c'est trimestre dit de
maternité peuvent dans certains cas dans
le cas où les femmes ont une carrière
complète ou quasiment complète perdre
d'une certaine manière leur utilité dès
lors où que la carrière peut être
complète sans pouvoir recours aux
besoins de cette trimestre et dans ce
cas il faut se demander quelle est
l'utilité de ces trimestre et l'utilité
de cette trimestre peut-être non pas de
compenser une incapacité à cotiser
pendant un temps mais à compenser les
inégalités de carrière que peuvent
encore provoquer susciter et
malheureusement le fait d'avoir des
enfants et de consacrer du temps à leur
éducation et donc l'alternative qui est
ainsi proposée à la fois maintenir ce
bénéfice de temps pour les femmes qui en
ont besoin du fait d'une carrière hachée
mais permettre à celles qui ont une
carrière complète ou quasiment complète
quelques trimestres avant l'âge
d'ouverture des droits de bénéficier
d'une surcote parce que finalement
la démonstration est peut-être un peu
simpliste si elles ont réussi à avoir
une carrière complète cela signifie que
leur grossesse leur maternité ne les a
pas empêché de mener une carrière mais
peut les avoir empêché de progresser
aussi rapidement que leurs collègues
hommes et donc permettre à ces femmes
qui ont une carrière complète ou
quasiment complète alors de bénéficier
non pas de temps validé mais d'une
surcote en termes de pension nous paraît
permettre une alternative intéressante
et
posant une première pierre une première
brique pour le chantier des droits
familiaux que nous aurons à aborder et
élaborer d'ici le pellet FSS 2024 j'ai
pris cet exemple qui renvoie là encore à
la complexité que j'ai évoqué hier pour
dire tout simplement et j'entamine par
là qu'une question binaire à laquelle on
apporte une réponse par oui ou par non
est une question trop simple trop
directe et donc une opportune pour
aborder une réforme comme celle-ci je
compte plus sur la richesse des débats
du Parlement pour permettre d'améliorer
le texte
[Musique]